first I want to mention something every
so often somehow we managed to get stars
from the world of entertainment to sit
down and share some of their innermost
secrets with us yeah I mean stuff I
haven't told anybody
dark sordid stuff tonight we have a very
famous actor who again for some reason
was willing to spill his guts for us on
camera it's pretty disturbing take a
look Winkler
people are always asking me which I like
best acting producing directing I mean
but choosing just one is like picking
your favorite child I mean literally
because I named my kids acting producing
and directing with secrets okay I'm best
known as an actor but my true passion is
pretending see greatness I don't own the
car I never did I prefer to get around
by a process that I call winkling I
don't care what Jimmy Carter says
Habitat for Humanity was my idea except
I called it digs for dudes
see the reason Fonzie went he is because
the show was on ABC if the show was on
NBC the Fonz would go and see I'd say
that half the groupies I had from
playing the Fonz thought they were Vinny
Barbarino Winkler
[Applause]